x-wing wing commander privateer thrust
master joysticks mark hamill ah yes the
early 90s when space flight Sims ruled
the roost these were the games that
drove you to upgrade your PC the games
that would later invert the controls of
a generation of console gamers these
games sparked our imaginations and early
glimpses of virtual reality fanned the
flames games like dactyl nightmares
movies like lawnmower man and books like
Snow Crash and then it was like all that
excitement just faded away some games
carry the torch like the x series and
EVE Online but the space sim practically
went into dormancy for a decade or so
but now in 2014
successful crowdfunding efforts and the
oculus rift have both created and
capitalized on some serious excitement
for space Sims so we're taking a closer
look at two of the most promising titles
star citizen and elite dangerous
star citizen is not a finished product
in fact if you only play officially
released content all you can do at this
point is walk around your personal
hangar and do a little target practice
and sit cozy in your ship's cockpit with
a stupid grin on your face but every
year to get my $40 spaceship into the
air
I took the downloading pearls playground
a community created mod that essentially
serves as half showroom half Garry's Mod
exhibiting the games engine at work and
a good deal of what's already been coded
though it clearly lacks the refined
sheen of a retail product there are AI
driven cars of a knee-high driven car
physics demonstrations spaceship
colliders exploding spaceships a turret
to shoot spaceships bits of spaceship
debris a multitude of mysterious
switches and a platform where you can
generate as many spaceships as you could
possibly want so many spaceships this is
also a unique opportunity to explore and
pilot a few of the games vehicles
without having to spend hundreds of real
dollars on a fleet of non-physical
objects though some of them seem to be
purely cosmetic at this point unless you
consider an interactive toilet seat the
defining element of a spacious
functionality which I for one actually
do now this tech demo isn't indicative
of the dogfight module that will soon be
upon us nor is it a true representation
of star citizen at large
there isn't a sufficient amount of space
to navigate a ship properly nor anything
to really do once you're airborne and a
lot of the elements that appear here
aren't a hundred percent complete
but Pearl's playground gives us a peek
and an infinitesimally small slice of
star citizen and there's definitely
something special brewing in this uber
ambitious spaceship simulator
elite dangerous hammers home that in
space up is a relative term it's a
delight to do something as simple as
enter a Space Station and realize you
have to dock on the ceiling or wait
there is no ceiling because now it's the
floor the lead is still in early
development but it already has a host of
campaign challenges and multiplayer
combat remember this move slip in behind
a capital ship so its guns can't get a
fix on you yeah take that capital ship
elite echoes mechanics of x-wing and
privateer losing a dogfight shunt all
your power into engines and make a run
for hyperspace win a dogfight open your
cargo scoop and gather leftover
spaceship alloys sorry can't capture the
pilot and sell them into slavery that
was pretty dark privateer earning money
from contracts and selling alloys in the
black market lets you upgrade your ship
weapons and gadgets fYI I'm not sure
it's a black market if you can do it in
the open so far oculus support is pretty
fantastic the ships interface is managed
by looking around your cockpit to the
left perform scans to the right manage
your ship's internal systems also when
wearing the oculus the ship goes from a
compacted flat surface on a PC monitor
into a cavernous space with HUD elements
existing several feet apart
some closer to you some further away
talking to you bobblehead girl with a
few weapons and ships already in-game
elite is shaping up nicely developers
are already looking at ambitious future
targets such as landing on planets ship
interiors and ship salvaging it's far
too early to tell what the final elite
game will play like but if you find
yourself with a lot of disposable income
you can get in on the game early
Natalija can figure out how to do my
business on this vacuum toilet the
future looks bright for space Sims even
though the full-fledged versions of
these games are still a ways off are you
intrigued skeptical excited leave a
comment below and stick around we'll
have more updates on star citizen and
elite dangerous in the months to come
right here on GameSpot calm